[Música]
momento de pasar a nuestra revista de
prensa de directo a América con Marta
Moya Buen día para usted Marta Hola
Ángela Buenos días yo sé que este tipo
de noticias a usted le llaman mucho la
atención CNN nos lanza una bomba el día
de ayer con un audio exclusivo en el que
el propio expresidente Donald Trump
acepta que sí tiene en su poder
documentos clasificados de la Casa
Blanca Así es Ángela el audio se
reprodujo ayer por primera vez en
exclusiva en el programa de Anderson
Anderson Cooper free sixty y son dos
minutos en los que Donald Trump habla
con sus asesores en su mansión de
badminster en New Jersey en el verano de
2021 seis meses después de haber dejado
la casa blanca y El Magnate republicano
habla textualmente que dice que lo que
les está mostrando son documentos
secretos y confidenciales el contexto
del audio es el siguiente unos días
antes el medio de New York que era había
publicado información en la que el jefe
del Estado Mayor conjunto de la defensa
de Estados Unidos Mark Milly decía que
tenía miedo de que Donald Trump atacara
o decidiera atacar unilateralmente a
Irán después de conocerse esta noticia
el audio se filtra esto se da unos días
después entonces escucha a Trump
visiblemente molesto con Marc Milly y
con los documentos en mano dice que es
el propio Mark Milly quien está pensando
en atacar a Irán que no procede de él
ese presunto ataque contra el gobierno
islamistad iraní esto podría ser una
prueba contra Donald Trump en este
juicio sobre los documentos clasificados
que hay en su contra Aunque Trump se ha
negado o sea se ha declarado Inocente de
todos los cargos penales que se le
imputan y ahora vamos a escuchar un
fragmento de este audio filtrado por la
CNN
dijo que yo quería atacar Irán no es
increíble tengo una gran montaña de
papeles esto acaba de aparecer Mira era
él me presentaron esto Esto es
confidencial pero me presentaron esto
esto era él Marc Milly el departamento
de defensa y él
esto es información secreta
Pues bien Marta Esta es una noticia que
está en desarrollo a lo largo del día
probablemente veamos reacciones desde
Estados Unidos pero por ahora quisiera
que cambiáramos de Cuestión porque
tenemos otra novela que se desarrolla en
Europa y es la novela entre Vladimir
Putin y el líder del grupo Wagner el
que está lejos de terminar al menos a
priori y vamos a centrarnos en la prensa
africana hay varios países que son
altamente dependientes de Wagner donde
Ahora hay mucha incertidumbre después de
este intento de amotinamiento del grupo
Wagner que anunció su marcha hacia Moscú
justo antes de un acuerdo que frenó todo
en un mismo fin de semana Así es Ángela
y por eso la prensa africana se hace eco
sobre toda esta novela vamos a empezar
con un medio guineano llamado
que titula la rebelión de Wagner es una
advertencia para Guinea Mali y Compañía
dice este artículo que los países en
África deben aprender varias lecciones
de todo este episodio del fin de semana
concretamente dice este medio hay muchos
países que han tomado la decisión
deliberada de vincular su destino tanto
a Rusia como a la milicia Wagner
naciones como República centroafricana o
Mali dice este medio han sacrificado sus
relaciones diplomáticas En beneficio de
un matrimonio exclusivo con Rusia han
sobrevalorado a Putin y a su poder y
ahora textualmente también los
neosseudorevolucionarios que contaban
con tal poder para someter a sus
compatriotas deben aprender algo de la
rebelión de Wagner está bien dice este
medio mayor respeto a Francia en sus
relaciones diplomáticas con los países
africanos Pero que sea una carta blanca
para Rusia esto lo deben considerar los
países africanos Por otra parte hemos
destacado el linfomatán un medio de Mali
que hace un editorial muy a favor de
Rusia y dice Mali no se equivocó de
socio con Rusia tras los acontecimientos
de las últimas horas dice este editorial
textualmente eminencias grises estimaron
que las autoridades de la transición se
habían equivocado en la elección de
socio estratégico en detrimento de sus
socios tradicionales los países que han
abandonado a Francia lo hicieron por su
falta de compromiso en la lucha contra
el terrorismo tras más de 10 años de
cooperación por lo que la relación con
Rusia y Wagner representa confiabilidad
y seriedad y por otra parte hemos
destacado el wakat Zaira un medio de
burkina faso que también hace una
editorial bastante más irónico que
titula entonces Wagner está en Mali
se abren un interrogante de qué va a
pasar con la fuerte presencia del grupo
Wagner ahora que está en entredicho su
futuro tras este intento de rebelión
contra el kremlin y que si el grupo se
disuelve en el ejército regular dice
este editorial ya no tendrán que
enfrentarse al dilema de elegir entre
privogen y el estado ruso los eventos
del sábado marcan un punto de inflexión
de Rusia en las relaciones entre Rusia y
en las Naciones africanas dependientes
de Wagner y aunque no se ha terminado de
resolver el Enigma especialmente en el
continente africano la rebelión contra
Putin ponen jaque la diversificación de
socios en África eso dice este medio de
burkina faso bueno Marta una decisión
para usted nos quedan dos minutos de
revista de prensa y todavía nos quedan
dos temas Así que si le parece avanzamos
en Guatemala las elecciones del pasado
domingo nos dieron una sorpresa con una
izquierdista que llegó a segunda vuelta
y se trata de Bernardo Arévalo hoy el
periódico el país afirma que rompió el
tablero tradicional pues se Angela
Bernardo Arévalo consiguió cerca de un
12% de los votos no estaba en ninguna de
las encuestas como favorito está al
mando del movimiento semilla que nació
tras las protestas sociales de 2015 un
politólogo citado por el país dice que
las claves del éxito de Bernardo Arévalo
son Por una parte el deseo de renovación
social y por otra parte y el rechazo de
la deriva autoritaria que está surgiendo
en Guatemala por otra por otros de los
candidatos a las elecciones a expensas
de lo que ocurra este 20 de agosto dice
el país Bernardo Arévalo ya ha logrado
romper con la política hegemónica en
Guatemala muy bien y vamos a cerrar con
un interesante reportaje que publica al
jazzira sobre una piloto de avión en
Texas que realiza vuelos de una manera
muy altruista para permitir que mujeres
que necesitan Acceder al derecho del
aborto puedan desplazarse de los estados
donde está prohibido historias como
estas se hacen cada vez más frecuentes
Así es Ángela es un reportaje firmado
por the Lane nolan y nos habla de
Michelle una profesora y piloto tejana
que traslada mujeres que no tienen
recursos desde Estados donde el aborto
está prohibido a estados donde todavía
Es legal los vuelos Los hace una
organización sin ánimo de lucro llamado
El better Access y cuenta la historia de
una menor que necesita un aborto y
Michelle la traslada junto con su
hermana mayor el reportaje no da nombres
por razones de seguridad para que no
haya cargos penales ni contra las
víctimas ni contra las personas que
ayudan a bueno que estos abortos se
materializan Michelle cuando tenía 10
años era cuando Robert se aprobó y una
amiga suya abortó de manera ilegal
cuando estaba en el instituto una época
de secretismo de los abortos indeseados
y los embarazos indeseados pero también
cuando empezaban a surgir esas medidas
anticonceptivas ahora Michelle dice que
no protesta pero que en su lugar fleta
aviones para trasladar a mujeres de bajo
recursos a estados donde el aborto
todavía Es legal ha habido amenazas
contra los pilotos de elevate Access
pero dice Michelle que no tiene miedo y
que su compromiso es con las mujeres que
desean abortar de manera legal y segura
Pues es que está claro que no va a dejar
de haber abortos Marta lo que sí puede
haber es más mujeres fallecidas Por
hacerlo de manera insegura Muchas
gracias gracias